bonjour et merci des trains sur rt
france vous le réclamiez depuis de
nombreuses semaines ce calendrier de
réouverture
les terrasses des bars cafés brasseries
restaurants ans pourront découvrir le 19
mai avec un couvre-feu repoussé à 21h et
des tables de six convives au maximum il
faudra attendre le 9 juin pour le report
du couvre-feu à 23 heures et l'ouverture
des cafés et restaurants est ce que vous
êtes soulagés soulager peut-être pas
nous avons aujourd'hui nous avons une
date
effectivement nous avons une dette nous
avons une date du 19 mai mais c'est un
pétard je trouve déjà que c'est en un
seul mois de mai parce que nous nous
inspirions entre le 10 et le 15 pour le
19 mai sait déjà que nos terrasses faut
savoir que les personnes qui n'ont pas
de terrasse ne pourront pas exploiter
leurs commerces
donc ça que c'est quand même limité
après un endroit le 30 juin à partir du
9 juin levée du couvre-feu
six personnes sur les terrasses et les
tables de six personnes nous tournons
que c'est un peu juste aujourd'hui nous
voulons reprendre le travail le plus
vite possible mais nous sommes tenus par
ces variants éparses et c'était le
silence par rapport à 100000 habitants
qui est encore élevé alors pas
d'indications sur les conditions de
réouverture
il vous faut plus de détails sur les
jauger les protocoles sanitaires pour
pouvoir ouvrir au mieux c'est à dire
qu'on aussi à peu près aujourd'hui sur
les terrasses
il faudra les tables pas plus de six
personnes pour les intérieurs c'est
quand même prévu c'est partir du 30 juin
c'est pas c'est pas tout de suite ça
fait rendez compte c'est le temps long
va être au mois de juillet nous aurons
pas à l'ouvrir nos établissements dans
leurs capacités
les gens vont partir en vacances pour
nous la saison la saison d'été est pour
ainsi dire appliquer parce que les
touristes soient il n'y a pas de
touristes
paris va se vider non moi je suis quand
même inquiet de la situation
ce qui me rassure c'est que le
gouvernement d'en conserver les add on
va conserver les aides allouées train
elles vont être appropriée mais ça
devient difficile aujourd'hui la
situation est à bout de souffle à
l'oreille du maquereau a dit vouloir un
pass sanitaire qui font les stades
festival et foires mais pas pour les
restaurants est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous déplorez déploré ne peut
pas déplorer pas ce qu'est ce que ça
aurait été appliqué ce que non non on a
besoin de travailler mais japon d'un
sanitaire on avait le cahier de rappel
qui a fonctionné aussi mais le passé à
lithaire pourquoi pas
nous ce qu'on veut c'est travailler au
plus vite les intérieurs capacité totale
est alors comment est ce que vous allez
vous préparer pour accueillir de nouveau
les clients après tant de semaines de
fermeture ça commence dès maintenant
déjà pour les terrasses la province d
même temps les commandes les jambes ont
commencé déjà à préparer leurs terrasses
à faire des mitrailleuses parce que on
en ouvrir les terrasses et ça c'est
certain
il faut préparer l'intérieur la cuisine
ne faut pas fonctionné cannelle le
personnel va être là il faut remettre
tout en route les frigos les mails et
tout remettre en route l'accompagnèrent
tout ça c'est pas mal c'est beaucoup de
travail pour une recette qui sera
j'espère en soit là parce que nous
sommes approchés à la météo aussi faut
pas oublier que si nous avons du mauvais
temps comme c'était le cas l'année
dernière on risque de repli éviter
d'autres nos terrasses et de rester à la
maison
alors justement concernant les terrasses
à paris la mairie à établir nouveau
règlement concernant leur extension
deviendrait payante comment est-ce que
vous accueillez cette nouvelle ce que
vous avez eu des contacts avec la mairie
paris des négociations
ça fait voilà quinze jours ou même plus
qu'on nous travaillons sur le sujet bien
sûr avec la avec les riverains perrin
permanence en contact avec une riveraine
amérique paris qui présente bien sûr
nous travaillons bien sûr nous allons
avoir ces extraits sur une terrasse qui
vont je pense nous faire beaucoup de
bien parce qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'établissements qui n'ont pas de
terrasse grâce à ces extensions dans
pouvoir installer une terrasse et les
certain que maintenant le problème c'est
que c'est la facturation interne que la
mairie de paris va maintenir jusqu'au 31
décembre
la gratuité de ces terrasses et les
contres terrasse provisoire est ce que
vous êtes toujours partisan d' une
territorialisation des mesures pourquoi
est ce que c'est encore la meilleure
solution selon vous alors je pense je
pense je suis même certain que le
président wacogne qui prendra la parole
à partir de la semaine prochaine a
annoncé peut-être des territoires qui
sont beaucoup plus ouverts et paris
peut-être comme l'a fait l'année
dernière on arriverait en dernière
position
tout est rattachée à la hauteur de
contamination c'est à dire que par
rapport à 100000 habitants sur des sens
à 100 à 100 cas pour 100000 habitants on
allait ouvrir le problème il est là on
est attaché c'est pas les politiques qui
nous gouvernent aujourd'hui c'est le
virus qui nous gouvernent
merci beaucoup d'avant réagi sur rtl
france marcel bénézet président
la branche cafés bars brasseries du
groupement national des indépendants de
l'hôtellerie et la restauration